ein neuer tag indem wir meine wohnung
kaputt machen
der nächste treff wird ein gewollt
irgendeine verpflichtung nicht so
komisch gewöhnlichen wie den buben ja
auch einfach anders ist karl mit nem
sind aufkleber alters geht nicht statt
hier unten im keller wird mitglied statt
leute bin übrigens erkältet habe die
letzten tage ca 70 test gemacht die alle
negativ waren und was ich mich erstmal
auf den beiden seiten mit irgendwelchen
apfel zitrone ingwer als
[Musik]
ruhig allerdings nicht raus gehen möchte
um mich halt gesund zu kurieren gute
belichtung luca ich jetzt heute den
ganzen tag damit verbringen meine
wohnung aufzuräumen wieder
wohin mache ich noch jobs über pekings
dumm schwimmen bolide ist gerade nehme
ich diese pflanze hierüber von nach
vorne hierhin und fasst sich hier eine
folgenschwere
vorgespielt war schon echt große
schwester einfach so eine wärmende augen
was gesamten dampfross japan geschenkt
und er
sagt wenn du das siehst keine ahnung
dass das hier für eine schatten
das ist das beste das ich je gemacht
habe
das hat innerhalb von drei jahren
zweimal den lotto-jackpot in höhe von 10
millionen dollar geknackt
chillig
kaufen dreier-pack tiefkühlpizzen also
nur zwei drin und dann zweimal nach
wir suchen den seit fünf minuten kanal
oder ist
ausdruck zu können lautet sich
hoffentlich sondern das ist eine angst
erhöht nicht wenn du den ruß update zum
thema wohnung aufräumen ich habe zehn
minuten was gemacht
und
danach säße ich jetzt zwei stunden
sondern auch gegessen und soll ja pause
gezielt einbauen und das ist mir wichtig
meine wand sieht einfach aus wie dieser
energy dass ich erschrecke ich für reife
einfach süßeste hamster der welt
und ich habe gerade zwei stunden dann
war der komplette obere etage ausgeräumt
das tier sieht auf jeden fall freundlich
aus ich war gerade zum letzten mal
duschen in einer kölner don roman extra
gleich mit augen bis vor die tür
[Musik]
ja eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt habe
ich noch gar nicht gesagt was sie alles
anders gemacht wird denn
eigentlich wird alles anders gemacht
es wird eigentlich komplett neu gemeldet
alles seinen drei monaten sehen und ich
weiß aber noch nicht wie wir den drei
morden schaffen wollen ich habe auch tik
tok sonne extrem geil trick gesehen
hier helfen
von sandra verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht
warum unterschied gemacht zwischen
grünglas augen gras und mais glas glas
glas hälfte gm in den kommentaren ist
sie geradezu lieber nintendogs wenn man
dass sie getrennt voneinander und sogar
eine halbe stunde hier im viertel kinos
angestanden um zeitungen zu kaufen weil
wir doch etwas entwickeln müssen was hat
man sie nicht richtig keinerlei weg wenn
die butter zu hart ist uns aufs brötchen
zu streichen stellte einfach in der
wohnung in die sonne
kein problem ein roggenbrötchen sind
einfach 11 aus dem bürger
dass ich mir dann denkt ja das ist gut
das parkieren
gefragt hat
die ganze sache fünf stunden später
ich hab keine ahnung wie wir das
hingekriegt haben wir sind jetzt auf
jeden fall in hamburg angekommen und
die haut weg aussehen sie hamburger
hundescheiße boxen einfach fabelhaft
die haben einfach meinen namen auf dem
boden geschrieben was andere und mama
verrat ich schwöre ich hast du diese
mülltonnen in hamburg hier deine sorgen
einwerfen haltefrist die aus der hand
kopf ich will keine schokolade ich will
lieber das papier alles klar der rein
oder nicht rein das ist keine frage
kugel ist dass das kind an die leine
nehmen guck mal da ist nähert muss diese
eine 20 quadratmeter blumenwiese ist
einfach schönheit ganz köln
hier sehen wir übrigens hamburg meine
lieben freunde meinen augen nehmen und
die schönen zustand in ganz deutschland
mit dem schönsten menschen aus ganz
deutschland
[Musik]
das wirkt sie so teufel
bitte jetzt an so wie es geht
naja
vielleicht die kamera aus
neue these von mir dann sieht nie gut
aus beim joggen man kann nicht gut beim
joggen aussehen perfekt was
du gehst ja nicht glauben weitere these
von mir hamburger style bei jungs und
mädels komplett gleich vom bauchnabel
rund haben
danke schön übrigens für 14.800 follower
hamster der reise in stara wer
allerdings eine kleine nachricht von
meinem manager
verlangen da eine ganz klare
stellungnahme von
den ganzen tag jetzt sieht man wird
kein gesicht
schädiger blog content wer muss was zu
essen bestellt
ist ihr eure kartoffeln eigentlich auch
immer mit
[Musik]
deswegen hat am lebensmittel bestellen
ich bestehe weiter nein luca bei mir sie
übrigens aber noch weihnachten
stift
jetzt folgt ein wundervoller time labs
wir beiden den einkaufswagen und fahren
das war es
die ganze zeit gefühlen wir zahlen jetzt
mal akkus dass wenn ich im supermarkt an
der kasse steht und das ist ein
richtiger wettlauf zwischen der
kassiererin und euch beim einpacken das
war es gerade aber ich habe grund
wir haben einfach 471 euro eingekauft
ich hoffe das reicht jetzt erstmal für
zwei tage übrigens hat mir diese sarah
der ich ja heute nachmittag dieses
henndorf all day hunde gif geschickt hat
geantwortet mit ihren fetten bern und
youtube daher schickte ich jetzt einfach
mal spongebob zurück einfach jetzt daten
mit einer mitarbeiterin
ich habe ganz normal gechattet wir
kochen jetzt kann das ziemlich hart für
mich
wir sind uns jetzt auf jeden fall wenn
es fertig ist nach sondern schränkt
zurück
[Gelächter]
ich glaube ich beende stehen auch
einfach mal den job